il a simplement dit qu'il ne pouvait
plus supporter que des musulmans meurent
tant en Afghanistan qu'en Palestine
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré au policiers
quelques instants après son
interpellation Armor rajapour miandoab
d'origine iranienne a tué un passant au
cri d'Allah Akbar ce samedi 2 décembre
15e arrondissement de Paris entre le
quet grrenel et le pont birakeim peu
après 21h Armand rajapour miandoab
brandit son couteau et frappe
mortellement un touriste allemand
originaire des Philippines puis la
saaillant traverse le pont et frappe à
coup de marteau deux passant qure
policiers tent alors d'interpeller mais
il plonge ses mains dans son manteau
expliquant qu'il est en possession
d'explosif avant de reprendre la fuite
il est finalement neutralisé au pistolet
électrique par deux autres policiers
dans un squir voisin selon nos
informations Armand rajap pour Mian
doyab avait été sous traitement
psychiatrique et neurologique avant de
l'interrompre en mars 2022 en accord
avec son médecin même si le juge
d'application des peines avait demandé à
ce qu'il reste soustaitement le médecin
coordonnateur ne l'avait pas estimé
nécessaire Iman yajapur mianap 26 ans
est né à Nui sur scène c'est au moment
de la nature naturalisation de sa
famille en 2002 qu'il francise son
prénom et devient Armand ses parents
auraient fui l'Iran des Mola et n'était
a priori pas du tout porté sur l'Islam
lui qui se définissait comme salafiste
selonin de ses amis de lycée devient en
2015 un promoteur de l'idéologie
djihadiste et envisage un départ pour la
Syrie en 2018 il est condamné à an de
prisons dont un avec surc pour
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
pour un projet d'attaque à la défense
lorsqu'il est interpellé on découvre que
son action a été préparée avec deux
figures bien connues du djihadisme
Maximilien thbaau et méina bouedir car
arm rajapur miandoyab gravité en pleine
djihadosphère selon le Centre d'analyse
du terrorisme il était en lien avec
Abdullah anzarov l'assassin de Samuel
pati placé en garde à vue après cet
attentat rajapon meandoyab avait menti
aux policiers disant s'être présenté
comme un repenti du djihad il était
aussi en lien avec larossiabala l'auteur
de l'attentat de mananville sur des
policiers en 2016 enfin Armand rajapour
miandoyab était en contact avec Adel
kmich l'islamiste qui avait assassiné le
père Hamel en 2016 à Saint-Étienne du
rouvret c'est à la prison de freine que
sa situation a empiré de nombreux
incidents graves ont éclaté durant toute
sa détention entre 2016 et 2020 et il
est passé à la fois par le quartier
d'évaluation de la radicalisation et par
le quartier d'isolement en 2019 il est
jugé avec un gros potentiel de passage à
l'acte violent envers les personnels il
sort de détention en 2020 et c'est
seulement en avril 2023 que
l'administration pénitentiaire cesse son
suivi pourtant fin octobre 2023 sa mère
avait elle-même alerté les enquêteurs au
sujet de l'état de son
[Musique]
fils